no to racism following the killing of
george floyd at the hands of the police
in minneapolis
there have been weeks of demonstrations
in the u.s against racist violence
and the black lives matter movement has
inspired hundreds of thousands of people
to take to the streets across europe too
the protests have triggered a new debate
here in germany
on everyday racism which figure show is
on the rise and which has a long and
troubling history
so our question on to the point racism
how to heal the
hurt
[Music]
welcome to this week's show where we're
going to try and cast some constructive
light on the racism and discrimination
that are apparently rooted in our
societies
i'm peter craven and these are my guests
emilia roig french my birth she is the
founder and executive director of the
center for intersectional justice
that's a berlin-based organization
combating all forms of inequality
and discrimination in europe now she
says as long as there is racism in
germany
the word race must not be removed from
the constitution
as some are proposing also with us is
brandon keith brown he's a classical
music conductor working with renowned
orchestras here in germany
who believes it's important to speak his
mind on issues like race and exclusion
and brandon says reflection on racism is
only tolerated when people of color
are murdered and a very warm welcome to
to muhammad am jahid an
author and journalist with the german
weekly d site who says
here in germany too we must have no
inhibitions in addressing problems of
structural racism
and above all police discrimination and
brutality
thank you all three for being here
emilia i would like to begin with you
something big is clearly happening
hundreds of thousands of people taking
to the streets in europe and the us
we've seen it all before are you
confident are you hopeful that this time
something more might come of it well
what i think is that what is different
from before
is that um there seems to be a
collective epiphany on
the fact that racism is real and that it
has really deeply
deep roots in our societies not only in
the us but also in europe in germany
france belgium spain italy
and um and in that regard i feel like
there's a
readiness to have open conversations
about it
and for example such a set uh would
i don't think it would have been
thinkable um five six seven
years ago um and and so that's why i'm
hopeful yes and hope
hope is different from optimism it means
that i
i have hope that things will evolve in
the right direction
it doesn't mean that there are um
concrete and material signs that show me
that it's the case currently
but what i see is that the fact that
in the mainstream we're speaking about
structural systemic racism
that we are speaking about police
brutality and also putting in question
the uh legitimacy of an institution like
the police
is uh giving me hope okay well tell me
this your organization we just have the
the name of the organization the center
for intersectional justice and it aims
to combat
all forms of inequality and
discrimination in europe
the question is how so how i mean we
have
a strategy that is uh very holistic and
we don't tackle the problem for just one
angle
um first of all from multiple access so
when we say
equality and justice for all we mean or
more like liberation and equality
liberation and justice for all um we are
not looking at discrimination from
single axis like it's been the case just
on the axis of gender
or sexual orientation or class or race
but we're
looking at the intricate relationship
that exists between all those
systems of oppression but also all these
discrimination dimensions
and then second we do this through
advocacy in the wider sense
so it includes of course direct
classical advocacy with policy makers
at government level parliament level we
work closely with the european
commission
um and the european parliament uh but
also
uh from the bottom of meaning uh working
with civil society
uh and trying to amplify a movement
through a change of narrative a change
of discourse when we speak about
discrimination
okay mohammed you have written about
everyday racism that people of color are
confronted with in majority white
cultures
what have you learned it's a fight
it's not easy because i can
see right now in germany a discussion
where a lot of germans white germans
especially they say oh racism and police
brutality that's something in the u.s we
don't have that in europe
we have right now the minister of
interior affairs
who is putting pressure on a journalist
who wrote a text about police brutality
threatening to sue her and that shows
how white supremacy
is trying really to stop this
conversation at the same time we cannot
do that anymore
because we are here and we are allowed
one example you have just given of
of discrimination here in germany is
your overall sense that you are living
in a society that is moving
forward or moving backwards i think it's
more visible
it's not about forward or backwards what
happened to george floyd the lynching
we just saw it on video that was
happening the whole time
and now people are starting to take
pictures
to tell their stories to have the
opportunity
to write books in the mainstream media
for example
that's that's the difference and i don't
think that i can at least say
oh it's getting better or it's getting
worse from my perspective so there's a
readiness that you talked about and
there's a there are
people the the the the people of color
community if you so will his
is getting a higher profile in germany
as a result
of a new level of consciousness
i mean also people of color you have
black stories you have
in germany a lot of um germans from
turkish descent or arab descent for
example
the consciousness comes because there is
more and more
there are more more voices who that
now they can speak and
say having said that there are more and
more other voices
trying to stop those people to tell
their own story
and to change something in institutions
how the society thinks about stuff
and also talking about resources
who can talk about what and how um
brandon
the classical music conductor we've made
the point already
at the same time you are somebody who uh
who is driven
to get a message across you are
vociferous in your protest about this
about the world you see around you tell
me more why are you so vociferous
well the classical music is the only
genre really that divides a divide
society by race and class in such an
extreme way
and what we're finding out during covet
is that whites playing whites for whites
isn't working isn't working for the
genres who sustain the genre
and what i believe if you want to change
the racial conscience of people you have
to affect their spirit
laws and politics of course is not going
to change the minds and racial
conscience of people
so what we need to do is to force people
to develop
empathy and i believe you can do that
through sound
getting people together of different
walks of life different nationalities
different religions different colors
different races together
and to share empathy through sound this
is a type of empathy that will go into
the puzzle that will go into the streets
and this is something that you can't
emulate through any other
aspect of society and you've been here
in germany you've been doing that for
four years
what is what's the difference between
for you between american society the
american society that you have lived in
the
german society that you do live in what
what
you know what would you like to
communicate to our audience about those
two
on the surface african americans
typically say at least they don't shoot
us here
very often they don't shoot us too often
here it still happens quite a lot and
it's not covered in the media in germany
um so on a surface level that
there's not this you know perpetual fear
of being
shot by the police but at the same time
the racism is more insidious and and
more
backed by the government the fact
there's no racial senses here
so the government of germany basically
says that racism doesn't exist
and that the and if you're not counted
the government of germany does not say
that racism does not exist
no i think what they say if i may um i
think what germany is saying is that
racism is an individual
interpersonal uh phenomenon and
that is not rooted in institutions and
in the system so there's
a lack of recognition of the existence
of systemic institutional racism
and racism individual racism is mostly
pushed to certain groups like neo-nazis
like you know bad people who are
intentionally racist
because we don't have this empirical
data it's very difficult to justify
everyday racism it's very difficult
in the united states we have this
empirical data in the uk you have this
data on
police brutality racial profiling it's
very difficult to find out about uh
discrimination in health care here
all of these things my sense is that
that is changing the
the the more information more statistics
more figures are being gathered and that
the
uh the battle will tell me no no it's
not actually
there's if i may there is there are few
studies for example about police
brutality in germany
against black people and people of color
i worked for years about
on this topic and there is one only one
study
really showing how big the problem is so
i also see
my the thing this should be
government-backed government should
investigate
incidences of racism in america it's
very complicated but the state and
federal government
investigate when you go to the cafe and
they kick you out they do it for free
here in germany you have to pay a lawyer
sure
the lawyer has white fragility the judge
doesn't want to deal with this either
they also have the same racial
conscience of white germans who are
racist you can't count on
the government to help people who are
victims of racism in germany
i can remember germany 20 years ago it
was a very very very different country
it was mono ethnic in
in large measure it was monocultural in
large measure
from my perspective it was the question
we had with just now whether this is you
know
society has changed whether it's moving
forward or backward my sense is that
germany has made huge steps forward
um well just one more thing um you know
the sociologist michelle lamont and many
sociologists
internationally when society becomes
globalized the more inequality is
created the more separation we have it's
like all in vinegar
people don't all hold hands and kiss
when the wall came down the east and
west
did not all hold hands and kiss it's
still fairly separate
when the refugees came the german people
all of them didn't just welcome them in
to their neighborhoods we still have
pictures on their resume if you have
wearing a heat job you're not going to
be invited you're not likely to be
invited for that job
why are pictures on the resume we're
still looking at the way people look
how imitation white german can you
become to have access to society
i don't know if it's really changed that
much yeah and also when you say that 20
years ago
germany was very monoethnic and
monocultural i don't think it was the
case it's just that people were
invisibilized
they were you know the generation of
so-called guest workers
uh and their descendants their children
and grandchildren
who did live here but they were recluded
in
certain areas and did not have access to
public discourse they did not have
access to
visibility in the public space and this
is maybe what has changed a little bit
i wouldn't even go as far as saying that
it has really tremendously changed but
what
has brought awareness as well is that
more and more people coming from
other countries people of color coming
from france from
belgium from the us are making their way
to germany and also
exposing those issues but we haven't
really gone beyond
the exposure and this is only right now
happening
um that racism is uh really has come
forward
i'm not really sure but maybe my house
you have been so patient but i'll bring
you in next we need to just move
okay don't go ahead it's yours okay uh
the long and the very toxic debate on
the impact of race has also recently
manifested itself here in germany and
europe and the us as well and a global
wave of protest actions against
monuments statues and other artifacts
celebrating and even glorifying racism
and colonialism they've been toppled
let's get a quick feel for what that's
all about and we'll talk about that too
there he lies christopher columbus this
statue
in the u.s state of minnesota stood for
one of the most important people in
world history
the man known as the discoverer of
america but for many people
especially those in latin america his
name represents the beginning of a
period of great suffering
marked by the oppression and
exploitation of the indigenous
population
the discussion over monuments
commemorating the colonial era has been
reignited in europe as well
including here in the english city of
bristol edward colston
is remembered as a philanthropist by
some and is a slave trader by others
the bronze monument has now been yanked
from its pedestal and shoved into the
harbor by protesters
across belgium numerous statues of king
leopold ii have been covered with paint
or pulled down to protest the monarch's
reign of terror
in the congo
[Music]
and in germany there have also been
demands for years now to rename
monuments and streets that pay homage to
germany's colonial past
to uphold or to tear down do we need to
rethink our culture of remembrance
well that's one big important question
first of all i'd like to go
right back to muhammad i was very rude
i'll cut you off there uh can you build
a bridge from what we've just been
taught
listening to to where you were and the
point you wanted to make
i'll try um it also depends where you
are
if you can see how homogeneous the
german society is
where the decisions are made that's a
very wide space
usually in journalism in politics in
civil society
and um the discussion also is for
example
what uh happens right now in berlin with
the anti-discrimination law
which is talking about police brutality
you have a lot of the first law of its
kind in germany
when i talk to my friends from the u.s
for example they are like you don't have
an anti-discrimination
law like i'm like yes we do not have and
a lot of
all the white men in this case i'm sorry
um
they are trying to say we don't need
this law this is discrimination against
police
um and and that's also this discussion
with this monument for example
who decides how our public space
we share it how the space looks like
usually it's not black people it's not
people of color
and usually um the backlash is oh you do
identity politics i mean
if your identity really matches an ugly
monument like this that's very sad
emilia thinks the debate is very
interesting brandon said he's tired of
it he's bored by it all let's get amelia
first of all the
the the statues the monuments debate
tell us where you're coming from there
well i think it's it's symbolically it's
uh very powerful
um because we see that it's happening
everywhere uh in the world and
uh so i'm coming back again to my idea
of a uh to the idea of a collective
epiphany knowing that we want to
um so i think it's what dua who said
this we want to lift the veil
of um it could be cold of silence you
know or the veil of uh
skewed history and uh and the images for
me are really
powerful in the sense that it questions
power and it questions the invisible
um objective neutral norm that is
supposed to represent history
and science and in that sense it's
raising a lot of voices
so many different perspectives and
telling one side of assist of history
and so there's an african prophet that
says um
until the lion can tell the story of the
hunt
only the hunter will be glorified and
this is exactly what's happening so
that's why by tearing down those statues
we're setting the record of history
right in the sense that we allow another
perspective on history to be shed and we
also
pay tribute and respect to the victims
and
survivors of um slavery
of the genocides that have been
committed uh against the naman hero here
in germany so few people know about that
for example
and so that's why i think it's uh it's
powerful and and really long overdue
so this is a very passionate take on
that debate you were you did say while
we were listening to the report uh
that's that you found the the debate to
become tiresome
well what why people really hate is
taking away their individualism
and when you generalize about white
people you become very defensive
the fact is that white people have to
decide to reflect
internally and stop focusing on the
externalization of racism
i grew up in the south lots of
confederate flags
lots of statues about slavery i know how
people
think and and how they really feel about
racism
taking statues down is not going to
change the racial conscience of
of white americans um it's it's
it's beautiful it's passionate but in
the long run
it's it's not going to change much but
don't you think that we need to have
like
change happening from very different
angles and that it's organic and that
you know having this can help as well
trigger changes
why people in america don't like the
look
and the feel of racism but putting steps
in place
to give cultural access and cultural
membership
to people of color especially musicians
like i'm coming from
they're not willing to do it tearing
down a statue
feels good it makes you look good and
empowers you but what happens after you
take down the statue
are you going to hire black people in
the workplace are you going to get black
friends
75 of all white people don't live around
black people
which makes the self-reporting of racism
suspicious
and it's even more so in germany so it's
wonderful
take them down of course but it's not
going to change anything
i would i was in charlottesville in
february and they have the same
discussion
and i had to i had the feeling there
it's a battleground it's a proxy
discussion for
so much more so i would argue it doesn't
harm if this ugly ass
statue is gone but also i would see
both of you and agree that it it does
makes it make a difference in the public
space but it does not change that so
many
black people and people of color are
living in the conditions
of course i want to take down the people
who owned my ancestors but
is it really going to change things i'm
not sure it's it's
lifting the veil yeah well
more than more or less every fourth
person here in germany has roots outside
the country and sadly these germans are
often excluded they're given a very hard
time
in large measure because of how they
look one case in point in corona times
is the many asian
germans who say that they are feeling
the brunt of racism on a regular basis
let's have a look
victoria corey wu is german her parents
came to germany
long before she was born she's used to
encountering prejudice because of her
appearance
after the corona outbreak began in china
and the first cases appeared in germany
this bad treatment intensified
she's experienced degrading looks and
some people make a show
of avoiding her she said a man called
out to her that she should be sprayed
with disinfectant
i have the feeling that since the
pandemic began i should go more
hesitantly through the streets
i make myself small and i'm afraid of
encountering hostility
i also have the feeling that even though
i live in berlin i'm just not perceived
as german
integration researcher nao ha isn't
surprised by this at all
the question where are you from i can
have german citizenship i can have a
german passport
and still be confronted with these
questions just because i don't look
german
what does it mean to look german
being stigmatized because of a different
skin color or a non-german ethnic
background
how do we solve our racism problem
muhammad that question that one question
there what does it mean to look german
seems so very significant
it does but i'm glad that you brought
this
example because during corona or when it
uh
started a lot of people told me oh we
are all
the same now because the virus does not
see anything
we're all in it together it's not it's
not like that intersectionally
we can see that different groups in the
society are hit in a different way
by this virus i came from the us to
germany and a lot of my friends in the
us they said at least you have health
care there
no it's not that easy because if you are
undocumented for example
or you have refugee status you cannot
just go to the hospital
and it's like just shocking that corona
is just showing the structures we are
living in here in germany
and if you do not look like a typical
german which is white then you have
often a problem okay so you're very
eloquently
once again outlined the problem that we
are faced with
the you know how do we move forward from
here and before before we came in
we were chatting together before the
program and you were saying the only
people who can change all this are the
whites
yes well i just want to say um after
this that
i believe integration and simulation is
not the answer i think we need to have
naked what i call naked acceptance
because integration
integration assimilation means to become
imitation white german
and and this is one of the most
difficult things about germany
is to accept people that don't fit this
particular image and as germany becomes
globalized it's just creating more and
more problems
but yes this is a problem that white
people can decide to
solve this is not something you can do
with money you can't do
do through legislature it's something
that white people have to develop the
conscience
to reflect on emilia what do you think
the white community can
contribute to all this well first of all
um
you mentioned that white people react
very defensively when
we take away their privilege of
individualism which is a white privilege
by the way because you know
a lot of people of color and black
people don't have the privilege to just
act
and speak for themselves you know like
anything we say here will going to be
inferred to
our entire ethnic groups and race um so
i think what's important is to confront
this fragility
the the fact that um uh when we speak
about racism why people get defensive
because they feel attacked personally
and they don't want to be seated and
seen as a bad person it's not what it is
about we're tackling a system
that has been in favor of white people
and that's the responsibility of white
people to see this and to detach
their ego from the whole conversation
and to
that's the only way we can move forward
um
to develop empathy as you were also
saying i think it's
really important that uh dominant groups
learn to feel empathy towards
minorities and that's something that we
learned from very early on
little boys little girls learn
from the early childhood to identify
and feel empathy towards boys non-white
people learn
to feel empathy and to identify with
white people why because they are so
dominant
in the media in stories in um
in films in television advertisements
etc and so that's why
there's a an imbalance of power and
privilege that needs to be
turned around and reshuffled we need to
really find power in that sense
and this can only be done if there's a
readiness to
put whiteness in question and to render
it visible to say
whiteness is the fundament of
or white supremacy is the fundament of
racism
so what do we do with it how do we
deconstruct the white superior norm
and that's what needs to be done that's
amazing thank you so much
for that you have half a minute on how
to
overcome how white people like me how
can i overcome my own racism
i think i need more than half a minute
for that but what i always say
is yes in the us you have got donald
trump but it's the discussion is 20
years ahead
compared to the discussion here in
germany we don't we don't even don't
have a language to talk about racism in
germany so this is the
okay guys thank you i'm sorry i've got
the time is too short
i i hope we have given you some food for
thought on what is a very very difficult
matter a very difficult debate
three excellent guests thank you all for
being here thank you
thank you cheers
[Music]
[Music]
you